[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
everybody to Talks at Google.
Thank you for coming.
My name is [? Egal. ?]
And today I'm
pleased to bring in
Dr. Nathalia Holt.
A few words about Dr.
Holt before she jumps in.
Nathalia, a fellow
Bostonian, is a former fellow
at the Reagan Institute of
Mass General Hospital, MIT,
and Harvard University,
the University
of Southern California,
and Tulane University.
She's a science
writer, and the author
of a highly acclaimed
book named "Cured,
the People Who Defeated HIV."
Today she presents her new
book, "Rise of the Rocket
Girls," which looks like this.
Her book does a
fine balancing act.
On the one hand she lays forward
an untold, touching, diverse,
and almost unbelievable story of
female rocket science pioneers
from the JPL Labs in
Pasadena, California.
On the other hand,
she captures a time
very different from ours.
Or is it?
Let me just quote, "Motherhood,
the career she was formed for,
loomed large,
believes one heroin.
Schoolteacher, nurse, secretary.
Those were the options
before her, ponders another."
Well, by November
9th 2016 the US of A
may be a tiny bit different
place, but for now
Dr. Nathalia Holt.
[APPLAUSE]
NATHALIA HOLT: Thank you.
I'm so excited to be
here today and talk
to you about "Rocket Girls."
I actually came across this
story in a very unusual way.
In 2010 my husband and
I were expecting a baby.
And we were having a really
difficult time coming up
with names.
My husband finally
suggested Eleanor Frances.
And I wasn't sure.
The name's a little
old fashioned.
And so I did what
parents do these days,
and I Googled the name.
And the person that
came up was a woman
named Eleanor Frances Helin.
And there's this beautiful
picture of her in the 1960s.
She's accepting
an award at NASA.
And I was just shocked
by this picture,
because I had no idea that women
worked at NASA at this time,
much less as scientists.
And so I wanted to learn more.
And what I found was
that she wasn't alone.
There was actually a large group
of women, all working at NASA.
They started in the 1940s.
And they were
hired as computers.
So before all of the digital
devices we have today,
a computer simply meant
a person who computes.
And laboratories needed
to hire computers
to do all the calculations
in their laboratory.
So these women started out at
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
in Pasadena, California.
And this is a laboratory
of misfits really.
It's a group that was
started by the Suicide Squad.
And some of them were
students at Caltech.
Some of them weren't.
But they did a whole number
of reckless experiments
at that university.
They ruined landscaping.
They mixed nitrous
dioxide with wood alcohol
inside one of the buildings,
creating a toxic gas that
ended up completely rusting
a brand new, expensive wind
tunnel.
And then finally, they blasted
off the side of a building
with one of their experiments.
And at this point
Caltech had enough.
They said OK, you
guys have to leave.
So they went out to this
isolated canyon in Pasadena
and started doing their
experiments there.
And at the time
rocket science was
considered a fringe science.
You would never want to call
yourself a rocket scientist.
It just wasn't something
that was respected.
And there was this
very pervasive feeling
in the scientific community
that the work they were doing
would amount to
nothing, and that it
would be impossible for a rocket
to ever leave the atmosphere.
So they continued
their experiments.
And then remarkably enough,
in 1939 they got a small grant
from the US government.
And this was actually
the first time
the government was investing
in rocket research.
And with this money they
hired two computers.
They hired friends of theirs,
a husband and wife team
named Barbie and
Richard Canright.
They were both
very good at math.
And so altogether
the Suicide Squad
started working on
something called JATO,
or Jet Assisted
Take Off, where they
strapped rockets on to
airplanes and then ignited them.
And they ended up having
some success here.
So here's a team with
one of their airplanes.
And you can see
Barbie on the far end.
She's the one in the skirt.
So pretty easy to pick out.
And because of
their success they
were able to get another grant.
And they were using this
technology now to lift bombers.
So with this new
grant Richard Canright
was promoted to engineer.
But Barbie was not.
And this was just to be
expected at the time.
Women were not engineers.
And she was really very happy
to have her job as a computer.
In the 1940s there were
so few options for women
interested in math and science.
And so she felt very fortunate
to have this position.
So with Richard promoted the
lab hired a few more computers.
They hired a man and two women.
And one of those women
was named Macy Roberts.
Now, Macy was a
lot older than most
of these young,
crazy, reckless people
at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory.
And so the director
ended up, in 1942,
making her supervisor of
the computing section.
And she decided that although
men applied to her group,
she wasn't going
to hire any men.
She wanted it to be all women.
And so today this would
be a lawsuit of course.
But back then the
idea was that she
wanted to create this really
cohesive family group.
And she worried that if
she hired men they simply
wouldn't listen to her.
And so she hired a lot of women.
And these women came from all
different kinds of backgrounds,
all different education.
But what I found when
I interviewed them,
and many of them are
still alive today,
is that they all loved math.
They just had a passion for it.
So the education, many of them
only had high school degrees.
And at the time college degrees
weren't really a prerequisite.
So this wasn't a big deal.
But some of them
did have degrees.
One of those is this woman
here named Janez Lawson.
She was the first
African-American hired
in a technical position at JPL.
And she had a degree in
chemical engineering from UCLA.
So today she would have just
been hired as an engineer.
But back then she was
hired as a computer.
So these women all
worked together.
They worked mostly
with paper and pencil,
but they also had these really
clunky Friden calculators.
And these calculators
look really complicated,
but they could do very little.
They could do sort of basic
addition, subtraction.
Later models could
do square roots.
And the women would have
races with these calculators
to see who could do the
equations the fastest.
But they really took a lot
of pride in their work.
And they felt like they were
on par with the male engineers.
They felt very respected
in their positions.
Even though, of course, they
were paid quite a bit less.
And so the women were
doing calculations
for early missiles.
They were working on the
Corporal, the Sargent missile.
And at the lab the
feeling was that they
didn't want to work
on weaponry, but they
had to to pay the bills.
But what they really wanted
to do was space exploration.
There simply wasn't
money in that.
But slowly they started
using this weaponry,
and twisting the
calculations they had made
for missiles into exploration.
And so we see this on
September 20th, 1956,
when the women used their
calculations for a big rocket.
And what they end up doing is
they take their calculations
for the Sergeant missile.
But they don't use
the full missile.
They take a small model
of it that the women
called Baby Sergeants, and
they strapped them together
like this.
And they put them
on different stages.
So they make three different
stages strapped together
with these Baby Sergeants.
They have a big
rocket on the bottom.
And on September 20th,
1956, they fire this.
And it's a really
big exciting moment
because they have so
much success here.
They're able to lift off this
rocket, called Jupiter C,
to an elevation of 3,335 miles,
which is a record at the time.
And although they are
so excited by this
there is a bittersweet feeling
too, because at the top
are just sandbags.
What they wanted to be doing
was launching a satellite.
And they could have
in 1956, and it
would have been the
world's first satellite.
But the contract had already
been given to the navy.
So JPL just had to wait.
On October 4th, 1957, the
Soviet Union launches Sputnik.
And you can imagine how
frustrated they are at JPL.
The women are just
seething because they
know that they could have
launched a satellite a year
before.
But finally, when a second
Sputnik is launched,
enough pressure is finally
put on the Eisenhower
administration
that they give JPL
the go ahead to do a satellite.
And so they work on this.
They take their Sergeant, Baby
Sergeants that are all strapped
together, they do
the exact same set up
as they had for Jupiter
C, but this time they
have Explorer 1, the
first American satellite,
perched at the top.
And on January 31, 1958,
they launch the rocket.
And in the control
room that night
are several women who are
instrumental to the project.
But probably none is more
important than this woman
here, Barbara Paulson.
So she had already been working
in the lab for a decade.
She started when
she was a teenager.
And this night she
is the one plotting
the trajectory of the
satellite as it leaves Earth.
And so she's sitting at the
light table with her paper
and pencil doing
this all by hand.
And over her shoulder
are Richard Feynman,
the famous physicist, and
the president of Caltech.
And everyone in the room is just
waiting for her calculations
to know if this mission
is going to be a success.
And when she finally calculates
that, yes, the satellite has
made it, the first American
satellite is a success,
the room just erupts
in celebration.
It is such an exciting
moment for Explorer 1.
And in that moment
is the birth of NASA.
Nothing will be the same now.
So now the women
leave behind missiles.
They leave behind
weaponry forever.
And they begin working
on space exploration.
And the hours change.
Now they're working a
lot of really long days.
They frequently have to work
24 hours during a launch.
They have to be there
in the control room
when a launch is happening.
And this is all happening
at the same time
where they're at the age
they're getting married,
they're starting families.
So this is Barbara
Paulson in 1958.
And there was no
maternity leave then.
So there was really
this expectation
that you would have
to leave your job.
In 1960 only 25% of mothers
worked outside the home.
And so the women at JPL
would hide their pregnancies
as long as they could,
knowing that they might never
make it back.
But at the same time that
they're becoming families
there's another threat looming.
And those are IBMs.
And what I found is that
at other NASA centers,
when IBMs came in the
humans that worked
as computers lost their jobs.
And this is frankly what I
expected when I first started
researching this project.
I figured that the women at
JPL would probably end up
leaving once computers came in.
But this didn't happen.
Instead they kept their jobs.
They were so valued.
And there was so much
distrust of IBMs at the time.
There was a feeling
that these machines
were really unreliable.
So it became the women who
were sent to the IBM training
schools.
They were the ones that learned
the early computing languages.
And they were the ones that
became the first computer
programmers in the lab.
So against my
assumptions, the women
stayed there
through the decades.
And it was that computers that
was constantly changing around
them.
And one exception is this
computer, an IBM 1620,
that has a really special
relationship with the women.
And it's kind of a big part
of the story in the book.
The women named it [? Cora ?].
And she kind of becomes a
member of the women computers.
She has her own little room, of
course, that's air conditioned.
But they have a name plate
outside the door that
has the names of all the
women computers, and then
[? Cora's ?] at the bottom.
So she's very
important in all this.
So while they're working on
this cutting edge technology,
they're also dealing with
gender norms of the day.
And one of these
was beauty contests.
So the lab did hold
these beauty contests.
And the women even
participated in them.
Barbara Paulson was a second
runner up and Miss Guided
Missile.
And that contest
was later changed
to Queen of Outer Space.
And these contests
just seem ridiculous.
But yet, what I found
is that really in a way
they highlight the progressive
hiring policy of JPL.
You couldn't have held a beauty
contest at any other NASA
center because they simply
didn't hire enough women.
And they were also part of
all of these social events
the lab had that was
really different at JPL
than other NASA centers.
There were constantly
dances and groups.
And what I found was that the
employees spent so much time
together at work, and
then so much time together
in these social
events, that there
were many important friendships
that were forged here.
And when it came time
for male engineers
to write up their
findings and to publish,
they often included
their female colleagues
on these publications.
And this was just
not done at the time.
This was so unusual.
And it really changed the
longevity of their careers.
So one of my favorite
beauty contest stories
is the Queen of
Outer Space in 1964.
And so at the time
they were working
on something called the Ranger.
And so these were early
probes to the moon.
They were trying to find
a landing site that would
be suitable for astronauts.
And there was a lot of
tension happening in the lab
then, because while they had
to do these moon missions,
the real focus for
many of the engineers
and scientists at the
lab were for the planets.
They felt that the moon
was not interesting.
It wasn't scientifically
important.
And what they wanted to do was
to get a spacecraft to Venus.
And so there were actually
competing missions
at the time to the
moon and to Venus.
And much attention
from moon missions
ended up getting
diverted to the planets.
And because of this what
we see is just failure
after failure of these
Ranger missions to the moon.
And Ranger 6 was a big moment.
They're waiting for the
lander to land on the moon.
They're trying to see if they
can pick the right landing
site that can support a lander,
and can support astronauts
in the future.
And so many of the
NASA administrators
are waiting in Washington
DC until they get word.
And President Johnson
is on the line.
They're waiting for the
signal to come through.
And as they're
waiting they suddenly
hear breaking in, "Spray on Avon
and walk in fragrant beauty."
And it turns out
that they actually
crossed feeds with the Miss
Outer Space contest at JPL
during this.
So this a very embarrassing
moment for JPL,
but even more
embarrassing is the fact
that Ranger 6 never makes it.
It crashes.
They still have another
failure on their hands.
And now they're
really at the end.
And NASA tells them, if
you can't make this work,
if you can't make this
next mission a success,
we're just going to
scrap the whole thing
and you're not going to
be a part of this at all.
And so finally Ranger 7 lands.
It is a success.
And they're able
to get the pictures
from the Sea of
Tranquility and realize
that, yes, this is a perfect
spot for astronauts to land.
And this, of course, happens
in 1969 with Apollo 11.
And the women's fingerprints
are all over this mission.
The Saturn 5 rocket
that started it
was a big part of building
on what the women did.
The fuel that was in
the rockets was all
developed from the
women's calculations.
And even those first
words, "One small step,"
was made possible because
of the Deep Space Network
that the women built.
So the other momentous
thing that happened in 1969
was the women finally
became engineers.
This is a really big moment now.
They're no longer computers.
They've gotten a raise.
They've gotten the prestige
of being engineers.
And one of these women
is named Helen Ling.
And she had an
amazing career at JPL.
After Macy Roberts retired
she became supervisor.
And she was a big force
in bringing women back
after they'd had a baby.
She was the one that would
do the calls to women
and ask if they wanted
to come back to the lab.
And she presented a very
strong example of this herself,
because before any
maternity leave
was able to sort of scrap
together enough vacation time
to take six weeks off after
the birth of her second child
and come back to the lab.
And so it's really
because of her
that they created this culture
of working mothers at JPL.
And now by the late '60s
she's on a new mission.
She's decided that
she really wants
to increase the number of
women engineers at JPL.
And the way she does this is she
finds women who are very bright
but don't have degrees
in engineering.
They have bachelor's degrees in
math, or in computer science.
She hires them and
then encourages
them to go to night school.
And because of
this policy, which
was really much like Macy
Roberts of hiring as many women
as she could, she was able to
fill the lab with engineers.
And one of those women
is named Sylvia Miller.
So Sylvia was hired as a
computer, kind of right
at the end of computers, and
then went to night school
for engineering.
And one of the early projects
she worked on in the '70s
was called the grand tour.
And this was a really
exciting project
to explore the solar system.
But unfortunately
NASA at that time
was undergoing
massive budget cuts.
So they slashed the project.
And what Sylvia and her
colleagues in this picture did
is they decided that they
didn't want to give up on this.
So they came in one weekend
and they designed this really
audacious trajectory to go
explore the solar system.
And what they did
was they figured out
a way to use something
called gravity assist
to move from planet to planet.
So they would send a
spacecraft out, and then
use the gravitational
pull of a planet
to spin it around and send
it off to the next planet.
And they kept this
all under wraps.
They didn't want to tell
anyone, because they
feared that if they told
the administrators what
they were doing the project
would just get canceled.
And so this mission
eventually became Voyager.
And it's because of
this mission that we
have all of these
beautiful glimpses
into the planets of
our solar system.
And one of the Voyagers has
even left our solar system
and entered interstellar space.
It's the first human
made object to do so.
And after working on this
Sylvia became director
of the Mars program office.
And so she worked with
many of the other women who
were once computers.
So Barbara Paulson, and
Sue Finley, and Helen Ling.
And that large group.
And they sent many rovers to
the red planet, some of which
are still roaming today
with all of their programs
inside of them.
And it really is incredible how
long their careers have been.
They've been 50 year
careers at NASA.
And in 2013 I held this
reunion of the women
at JPL, where we brought
back as many of the women
as we could to the lab.
And I was really shocked to find
how little recognition there
has been of their work.
In 2008 NASA held a big
gala in honor of Explorer 1,
the first American satellite.
But they didn't invite the women
who were a part of that night,
not even Barbara Paulson
who was such a critical part
of that mission's success.
But probably the most tragic
of the stories is Sue Finley.
So Sue Finley was hired
in 1958 by Macy Roberts.
And she is NASA's longest
serving female employee.
But in 2004 NASA
decided that if you
don't hold a bachelor's degree
you can't be an engineer.
And Sue Finley, who
was hired at a time
before bachelor degrees
were really necessary,
was then demoted.
And so her engineering
title was taken away,
and she was put on
an hourly salary.
Despite this, she
loves being in the lab.
She's currently working on
Juno, our mission to Jupiter.
And really the only sad part for
her is filling out timecards.
She loves her job and her
work that she's doing.
So writing this book I feel
is important for bringing
recognition to these women
who really deserve it.
But it's also important for
women in technology today.
We're seeing a very
sad situation, where
in 1984 37% of all bachelor's
degrees in computer science
were conferred to women,
and today that number
has dropped to 18%.
So my hope is that these stories
can serve as an inspiration
to women that are interested in
pursuing these careers today.
So we did name my
daughter Eleanor Frances.
And she is named, in part, for
a woman that I have never met
but whose story I hope will
one day inspire my daughter
to do some exciting things.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: That's a great story.
Thanks.
And as you implied,
it's not unique.
You know, there are a lot
of other organizations
where the human computers,
mostly women, transitioned
into programming.
IBM itself, for example,
a lot of famous women
from the sort of earlier
days of programming languages
and compilers, and so on.
But, again, as you
point, that does
seem to be going
away, going backwards.
Do you have any thoughts about
why, or how to address that?
NATHALIA HOLT: Yeah.
It's interesting.
I think an interesting
case is Harvey Mudd.
So in five years they increased
the number of women graduating
with degrees in computer science
from 12% to I believe 40%.
And they made a
number of changes.
They made changes
in the structure
of their introductory
computer science courses.
They made some other changes
offering more research
opportunities and sending women
to a conference on females
in computer science.
And I think it's probably
a combination of things.
But it's nice if we can
look to programs like that,
and see the changes
they're making
that hopefully can inspire.
I do think it's important
to have role models as well.
I know for myself there's many
times when I've thought, well,
if Barbara Paulson
did this in 1959,
I'm sure that I can
manage it today.
So there is value
to that as well.
AUDIENCE: You said a lot of
these women have retired since.
Do you have a sense of have
they gone on to do other things,
or are they just, you
know, hanging out?
NATHALIA HOLT: Oh, they had
very long careers at JPL.
I mean, they had
50 year careers.
So now they're mostly in
their late 80s, early 90s.
So I mean, it's amazing
how active they are.
And it's incredible how
vivid their memories are.
I was really shocked
by that, just how
much detail they can
remember of how missions went
and what their life was like.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'm just trying to figure out
how to use that experience
to motivate other people.
I guess your book is
the way to do that.
NATHALIA HOLT: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: This may seem
like a silly question,
but the women that
were hired initially
because they were good
at math, how did they
become good at math?
I mean, women were
actively discouraged
from taking math courses.
And math seems like it's
a little less accessible
than other subjects like
maybe history, or philosophy,
or something like that.
What did they do to
gain their math skills?
NATHALIA HOLT: You
know, it's interesting,
because it's not
always that they
did that well in their classes,
but they really enjoyed math.
And I heard over and over again
that they were the only girl
in their math classes.
That was certainly a common
thread that went through.
Most of them took as much math
as they could in high school.
So I think it really just
comes down to their passion
for the subject and their
ability to pursue it.
There's a few cases
where even women
that didn't graduate from
college, such as Sue Finley,
she did take some college math.
And she couldn't get
the math that she
needed at her women's college.
So she ended up going
to a men's college
and taking courses there.
So they found a
way to get it, even
if it wasn't as accessible as
it could have been at the time.
Thank you so much for coming.
[CLAPPING]